in bad mom's mila kunis plays Amy a
hard-working mom who gets fed up trying
to be perfect I'm so tired of trying to
be the perfect mom and I'm bad moms but
in real life Mila is just getting
started
she's currently expecting her second
child with her husband Ashton Kutcher
here's what the 32 year old told et's
Kevin Frazier on Thursday at a special
screening of the comedy in LA is it
easier second time around I think with
the first one you're just so like
enamored with like the finish to
experience that now my only aim I'd like
you just kind of cuz you're just busy
running after the other one and then
working full-time it's just I don't know
if it's easy it's just different it's
just very different let me flip the
script what if your husbands were bad
and there was bad dad what would be in
that movie what scenario would play out
with your husband as a bad dad baby's
projectile poop and it was like one of
those days where it was just a lot poop
when I turn around he's like I got a
babe that's it great and then I turned
back around and he literally bathed her
in the sink which is fine and then
wrapped her in an entire roll of paper
like the you know the paper towel entire
roll and I literally like what happening
she was like cocooned in this little
lake bouncy roll and I was like oh my
god I love you so much it may be so
happy it's like 70 photos of it and
literally I was dying laughing